well Sophia isn't the only one who is I
love this video entertaining when she
was young um here's Sophia and Caruso
getting ready to perform as a kid listen
to what happens after her dad introduces
her
ladies and gentlemen I would like to
introduce to you
Sophia Caruso
[Applause]
now Sophia will be singing God Bless
America and now I won't
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I know I love at a young age you were
like I will do it when I want to I feel
like it reminded me so much of my
daughter I was like when she was like
not on your time sir I love I love that
were you always like did you always kind
of know yourself like that when you were
a kid like when you want to do something
when you didn't supervillous as soon as
somebody tells me to do something I do
the opposite oh my God ever since I was
little reverse psychology your parents
must know this trick well okay yes yes
yes they do
um yeah as you can see in that video and
also with my character too she's kind of
like that like yeah she's the good girl
and then she's suddenly the bad girl
yeah it goes against the grain I love
what you just did with your shoulders
because like you walking through like on
the little sneak peek we did I was like
okay music video like she's ready I was
like that was it was so cool yes yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody